- Nutritional information
on TikTok can be good,
or absolutely terrible,
and we're about to react to all of it.
Also, thanks to Butcher Box
for sponsoring this video.
Stay tuned to see how you can
get free ground beef for life.
(imitates computer beeps)
(intense pop music)
Mac and cheese?
That was hot! You gotta be
careful eating that hot.
Remember I have a whole
video on drinking hot fluids.
Increase their risk of
developing esophageal cancer
by 90 percent.
(intense pop music)
I don't understand this,
like he just ate some
yummy mac and cheese,
and he's going ham now?
(glass shattering)
(squishing popping noises)
Is that ASMR honey?
I want it!
Oh my god I love honey so much!
It's not really healthy
to eat in large amounts,
but guys, honey has
legitimate medical uses.
(squishing popping noises)
Oh it's so good!
You know there's also medicinal honey?
Like Manuka honey can be prescribed
for wounds that are poorly healing.
When I've worked at a
wound care center before,
in patients that had multi-drug resistant
bacterial skin infections
we gave them topical honey.
And it worked, it's incredible!
- Have you ever wondered how Koreans
maintain their good bodies even
after a big feast like this?
- Is that true?
Like I don't know if
that's medically accurate.
- You need to drink this once a day.
They contain Garnicia Cambogia
and they work to stop carbs
from being transformed into fat.
(record scratching)
- Time out!
There was a very famous doctor
that decided to call this a miracle cure.
That said you don't need to exercise,
you don't need to diet,
just take this supplement,
and it'll help you lose weight.
It's poop, never been proven!
In humans the results have
been mixed to negative.
So stop promising people miraculous cures.
Even Memorial Sloan Kettering,
which is where my mom ended up
getting her cancer treatments
before she passed,
has like a whole page on this,
we're gonna pop it up here,
to show that the results do
not show this thing works.
- [TikToker] Bro, why
do you eat your fries
before your burger?
- Look the logic behind
this is fries are carbs,
and they're gonna process way faster
than the protein in the burger,
so I want the protein
to fill me up at night,
and make me feel full.
(sighs)
- I hate saying the word bro science,
but if you're eating it four seconds apart
the way that it looks
in your stomach is like,
(chair thuds)
(arms slap)
So it doesn't matter if
you eat this bite first
and this bite second, in
the end, it's all like that.
(cougar roars)
Whoa, is that a cougar?
(hisses)
You know what's funny I
always get the cats wrong.
I'm like oh panther!
And they're like no cougar!
I'm like oh cougar!
They're like no panther!
I'm like oh puma!
They're like no panther.
(cougar growls)
I would not mess with that thing.
It could be like a lynx.
I don't even know there's so many cats.
- Where's the cheese?
I asked for extra cheese!
- I'm not gonna lie when
my cholesterol levels
were through the roof it was 'cause
I was ordering pizza with extra cheese.
That's a surefire way to
get your cholesterol up.
- Times running out!
- Okay, probably have to have a
dermatologist chime in here,
but I'm pretty sure the oils on the pizza
also not great for the face.
They probably cause breakouts.
What did I miss in this video?
Why are we slapping ourselves with cheese?
(high pitched beep)
- [TikToker] This is a bottle
of Dr Jayne's expectorant
from the 1800s.
- How did they get their hands on that?
Wow, with the one cent stamp on there!
- [TikToker] It still has
the original label on it.
And it's completely full.
- It's completely full but
it's so inert it's crazy.
It says alcohol 13 percent,
you don't think that alcohol has already
(cowbell)
expired, no what's?
When the sun shines on water and the?
- [Sam] Evaporate?
- Evaporates!
You don't think all the
alcohol has evaporated
from this bad boy, come on now?
- [Sam] Would it evaporate
if it's been sealed?
- Yes, unless it was kept in
like the most ideal condition.
The cork based on the
conditions and the humidity
will change shape,
and that will allow some
air to get in there.
- [TikToker] It says it
contains alcohol and opium,
and it's for children 14 to 21 years old.
- You know what we were
doing not that long ago,
and some doctors still do?
And in rare cases it might be okay.
Giving codeine as a cough syrup.
We have now taken a pretty
firm stance to say that
the risks outweigh the
benefits for codeine.
It's an opioid.
Back to the TikToks in just a second,
but first I wanna talk
to you about Butcher Box.
As some of you know,
I've completely transformed my diet
in the last year as I prepare
for my debut as a pro boxer.
I'm working out twice a day,
and I have a very strict
nutritional schedule
to make sure I'm in fighting shape.
This could've easily become a
process of eating bland foods.
But thanks to Butcher Box,
my meals have been better than ever.
Butcher Box delivers 100
percent grass fed beef,
free range organic chicken,
wild caught sea food,
and so much more directly to my door.
In particular I've been enjoying
their wild Alaskan Sockeye Salmon,
which is fresh and flavorful,
while also being packed full of nutrients.
Butcher Box only sources
from farmers and fishermen
who meet the highest standards of quality.
And you can choose your
box and delivery frequency
so you get the exact foods
you and your family love.
If you click the link in
the description right now
Butcher Box is gonna give you
free ground beef for life!
That's right new members will receive
two pounds of grass fed ground beef
for the lifetime of their membership.
Alright let's get back to the TikToks.
(whooshing sound)
(bells chiming)
Why are my evil arch nemesis back?
You know like they do
all these cap not cap,
this is pure cap.
Cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap!
(windows error sound)
They're putting crystals in here,
they're just throwing
everything in the book.
Is this sponsored by Goop?
Rub on belly and thighs
during the waning moon.
I'm not gonna lie I might
rub it on my thighs,
'cause my thighs have a problem!
Maybe this can fix the
energy in my thighs.
(people yelling)
Ooh, that was dope!
I didn't expect that to be that cool.
When kids say they don't
drink water add lemon juice,
cucumber, jelly beans?
(record scratches)
What do you want your kids to choke?
Olive oil, whipped
cream, sprinkles, tadaa.
So you just gave your kids
an olive oily milkshake?
(laughs)
I don't understand.
- Ultimate diet hack,
this is a little 25 calorie marshmallow.
- I hate the word hack!
(screams)
- All you need is five
seconds in the microwave,
and dude, look.
(microwave beeps)
- Okay that's not what
happened that's a lie.
But that was deceptive video editing,
and there's probably so
much refined sugar in there.
Oh my god it's so easy to
over do it with excess sugar.
That's how your body
starts getting confused.
That's how it actually
starts poisoning your gut.
Now when I say your gut,
I'm really talking about the gut bacteria
that live in there.
By eating all that refined
sugar you're feeding
and changing the type of
bacteria that's in your gut,
and increasing the number
of bacteria that love sugar.
Thereby changing like
the gut mind micro biome
where it's encouraging you to eat more
and have sugar cravings,
just be really careful.
Like if you go camping and
you have some marshmallows
not the end of the world.
(intense drum music)
(laughs)
Isn't that thing just
like a pure sugar cookie?
Like just a ton of sugar.
Same talking point as marshmallows,
lots of refined sugar, no bueno,
but if you're doing it for a competition
and your life's on the
line better get to licking!
And by the way, do you know
why the licking thing works?
It's because your mouth has saliva in it.
Saliva has salivary
amylase which is an enzyme
that breaks down carbohydrates, sugars,
and the parts that are the smallest,
meaning where the cutouts are,
dissolve the fastest,
therefore you're able
to push the cookie out
with a beautiful star.
(whooshing sound)
Five reasons you should
do a juice cleanse.
Okay this is hard for me to debunk.
'Cause you should give your
digestive system a break
from processed food,
but you don't need to juice cleanse
in order to give it a
break from processed foods.
You can just eat unprocessed foods,
which are whole foods and healthy foods.
You like beet juice? Eat beets!
You like orange juice? Eat oranges!
Why do they wanna drink everything?
Just chew it, you have teeth!
Two kick starts weight loss.
No, you do not need to kick
start your weight loss!
You know what eliminates
toxins? Your organs.
Your organs clean out
toxins, kidneys, liver!
You have 'em, use 'em.
Boosts energy, it doesn't
even say "boosts energy,"
it says "boots energy!"
(high pitched beep)
- Are you trying to cut carbs,
but it's really hard to do?
- Get a knife.
(laughs)
I don't know why.
- Let me show you how.
- In segments, in wedges, in slices,
- She took my joke.
- Cutting carbs is hard, use a knife.
- Wow she literally stole my joke, okay.
Or I stole hers.
(whooshing sound)
(people talking)
Oh I think I've seen this
video on my TikTok before.
This is like an Esophageal Dermal Fistula
where if you have a connection
between two parts of the body
you can create a fistula,
which essentially creates a passageway.
- I'm turning vegan.
(record scratches)
- Is he really?
(upbeat music)
Oh wait what?
So okay, it looks like steak
what does it taste like though?
- I have two simple solutions
for how to wake up happier.
- I wake up pretty
miserable the last few weeks
training for boxing, so
let's see what we got here.
- Take about 400 milligrams
of Magnesium Glycinate.
Magnesium is the mineral responsible
for over 3000 enzymes in your body.
If you add a couple magnesium pills
and a full glass of water before bed
you'll start waking up feeling incredible.
(whooshing sound)
- That last part why?
Why make a promise that if
you add a glass of water
and magnesium you're gonna
start feeling incredible?
My friend, walk into my medical office,
to my patients who have
been suffering with insomnia
for two years that are in tears,
severe depression because
of their insomnia,
and make this promise.
And watch them feel even more debilitated,
more upset because your
little life hack didn't work.
Stop the promises, it truly hurts people.
It's not the same thing to say,
magnesium has these actions in cells,
as saying taking a bunch more magnesium
will make these processes better,
or faster, or more efficient.
The reality is if you
don't have the magnesium
those processes don't happen.
But it should be talked
about with their doctor.
Not from a random TikTok
video promising you success
and probably selling you
supplements on the side.
(explosion)
- Tap water healthy for us to drink?
Let's find out.
- Yes.
(laughs)
I solved it, yes.
- Now what I'm gonna take is some
medical grade alkaline water
(windows error sound)
just so we have a
different water to compare.
And we'll test the PH,
we'll see what the PH is for tap.
- Oh thank god let's test that PH.
- Now in the United States of America
all tap comes out alkalineish, right?
And the reason is because
the federal government
mandates that it has to be like this.
They put chlorine,
fluoride, arsenic, lead,
(record scratches)
- Oh yeah they put lead in your water.
Bro do you hear what you say sometimes?
They actually limit how much
arsenic and lead ppm can be there.
- I have a straw, we'll blow
bubbles, and we'll compare.
- What is chemical versus molecular?
These videos they just take
words that are scientific
chemical versus molecular
here is just three words.
That's it, no meaning, just three words.
- And what happens when we
put it inside of our body.
- My friend here's what
happens when you put
your alkaline water inside my body:
It mixes with my stomach acid,
which has a PH of two on your
little red acidic scale there,
and it ends up being two.
Because the stomach acidity
is very tightly controlled,
and then it continues on
its way down to the gut.
And then it gets absorbed,
and then it enters the bloodstream.
And the bloodstream's even
more well controlled PH
7.35 to 7.45 even if the blood PH range
slightly comes out of that,
slightly, it can become lethal.
So your little one PH difference
in your little water bottle there
that you're charging
hundreds of dollars for
is complete poo poo!
- Larry King here.
- Our boy Larry King's back!
- Eat your heart out primals!
- He's literally eating a beef heart.
When I was watching the videos last time
I didn't realize that he
was gonna be consuming
all of the meats raw so
I didn't comment on it.
But you guys rightfully pointed it out.
The reason we cook our meats is because
we wanna kill the bacteria
that's found on them, in them.
When you consume them raw a
lot of times you'll be okay,
'cause your stomach has hydrochloric acid,
your body has an immune
system, but the problem is,
the one time that that
little Listeria, Salmonella,
it gets through, you're gonna
have a really big problem.
I believe in the hygienic theory.
Like kids should play in the mud,
like we need more bacteria
on us, around us, in us,
But this is in an unnecessary way to do it
in my opinion.
At least to recommend to everyone to do,
because most people don't know
how their meats are processed,
they don't know who's touching them,
and because of that you just don't know
what kind of bacteria's on there.
So cook it and be safe.
(soft beeping)
I mentioned intermittent
fasting in this video,
but here's a whole video dedicated to it.
Huge thank you to Butcher Box
for sponsoring this video.
Remember if you join now new
members will receive two pounds
of grass fed ground beef
for the lifetime of their membership.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
Intermittent fasting.
(upbeat music)